el estallido social en colombia' relegó
al menos temporalmente la pandemia a un
segundo plano sin embargo el virus sigue
latente y los contagios van en un
peligroso aumento la dicotomía entre el
control de la pandemia y la resolución
de un profundo conflicto social se
antoja difícil dado que el gobierno y
convocantes del paro parecen todavía
lejos de un acuerdo
nos preocupan las aglomeraciones por las
marchas y la protesta
el llamó al gobierno y a los coordinados
del paro es que se de una pronta
negociación si para que para que evitar
mayor transmisión estamos ante un grave
problema de salud pública de aumentar la
mortalidad si siguen las operaciones el
país suma ya más de 3 millones de
contagios y más de 78 mil decesos cifras
que acercan al sistema sanitario al
borde del colapso
incluso bogotá a la capital atraviesa
una situación inédita lo que se rompió
en colombia hace dos semanas y en bogotá
en particular fue el pacto
de cuidado ciudadano
que nos ha salvado la vida durante 15
meses y cada día que esté roto
ese pacto de cuidado colectivo nos
exponemos al riesgo de muerte masiva
entretanto el ministerio de salud
informó el lunes que ya se han inoculado
más de 6 millones de dosis de vacunas en
todo el país
sonia también más de 2 millones de
personas quienes han recibido una
segunda dosis esto en un país de casi 50
millones de personas a pesar de la
delicada situación sanitaria muchos
colombianos afirmaban tener más miedo al
hambre que al virus por lo que este
miércoles regresarán masivamente a las
calles de todo el país en una nueva
jornada de paro y protesta contra el
gobierno